you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
between two chess legends on the white
end the highest-rated female chess
player ever
Judit Polgar she is paired against
arguably the greatest ever chess player
Gary Kasparov this was from the Russia
versus the rest of the world match held
in 2002 let's have a look
pulgar opening with e4 because part of
replying e5 we go down a really Lopez
line the Berlin defense to be a bit more
exact and we go straight in for a main
line where we soon have the Queen's long
gun we're just eight moves in what are
some of the positives for both sides
well for white they enjoy a nice four
versus three majority on the kingside
this is a long-term advantage when we
compare that with the black side well
what is a positive on the black side it
lies greatly in having the bishop pair
so both sides will try to put their
Trump's to use so we get on with some
development here at c3h6 rules out any
pivot on the g5 Square D 1 black commits
their King back to his home square H 3
this is a step in the direction of
mobilizing White's King side majority
white does not want to be too quick to
play G for the short story here is that
if you play g4 you want to make certain
your you maintain your pawn on g4 if he
is having to move or make a capture that
weakens f5 and that can severely weaken
your attempt to expand on the Kings side
so h3 is an excellent prepping this
highly committal
G for advance right away we follow with
Bishop e7 Knight to e2 why exactly this
move some things to note about the
knight position on e 2 for one it looks
to reposition by way of d4 at some stage
or even f4 both squares would challenge
a light square Bishop position on e6
additionally for as long as the knight
remains on c3 there is this possibility
and it's uncomfortable 1 for white
there's this possibility that black
can't put pressure on the c2 pond for as
long as the Knights on c3 c2 can't move
of course and if we can imagine a bishop
one day arriving on f5 it because it can
become quite uncomfortable to defend a
pawn on c2 light is to take some extra
precautions in these position types
where they are lacking a light square
bishop so some extra square in
particular some extra Cuellar towards
the light color squares is important
taking steps to make sure you won't be
vulnerable to light square pressure is
important if instead of this Knight to
e2 move just to illustrate and I'm just
making dummy moves here on the white end
instead of the game move Knight to e2
suppose just a king move to illustrate
this is what I'm talking about
if this square is made available to the
light square bishop at some stage the
pressure on c2 is very difficult to
address ok just to again illustrate the
idea here it's one of the other ideas
behind Knight to e2 should it be
attacked at this point it can always
simply move it won't need a babysitter
so Knight to e2 it is white goes
straight in for this night to H form of
welcoming another minor piece exchange
this is also opening up that
f-five square for the bishop to pivot on
so the Knights are exchanged Bishop III
some more development the bishop
declares its intention and now we have
Knight to d4 this is a fine way to
address the threat against c2 it's one
of those counter attacking moves defense
and throwing a punch right back at black
and a important decision for black where
exactly to go with the bishop black
chooses to tuck it in on h7 this move
here maintaining pressure on c2 and for
the moment this night can't go too far
c2 would drop and so what follows now is
white setting into motion there King
side majority some with g4 and this is
also allowing the knight a pivot square
on f5 Bishop e7 King to g2 slowly
improving the King position he will the
White King will act as a good let's say
supporter for this white King side
structure if any of the pawns are
attacked the king is close by to lend
some support lend some defense h5 trying
to break down the structure some white
does not budge with the g4 pond but
instead pivots on f5 this is striking at
g7 bishop f8 not so quick to give up the
knight or excuse me not so quick to give
up the bishop for the night so Bishop to
f8 on developing but still maintaining
this structure King to f3 slowly
improving the King position bishop g6
preparing to make a capture and then at
least the rook has some possibilities
along the H file white is now doubling
on the D H takes G H takes black throws
in a check King g2 rook now goes back
and
King now steps up to g3 this is this
moment here it may be hmm quite tempting
by white - let's say double on the D
file however this can now be cut
uncomfortable for white capturing an f5
and then playing rook to h5 not so
easily seen how to defend a5 you can't
so the King g3 move you know
white does not go with just routine like
stuff King g3 is aimed at being in a
position to me rook h5 with simply king
g4 in the king will have a perfectly
fine role of defending that f5 pawn so
king g3 it is on this move 23 f6 Bishop
f4 this is a strong move this is eyeing
up the c7 square this is hmm in a way I
mean earlier I was pointing out the
white pawn on c2 and how if there's a
knight on c3 it can't move and maybe
it's vulnerable for as long as white has
this pawn on e5 it's difficult to see
how c7 could somehow be vulnerable but
as soon as f6 is on board one can
already start to envision okay the e
pawn and F pawn have been exchanged and
we now have this new diagonal so we can
access the c7 pun and white hops right
to it Bishop f4 it is not even capturing
capturing on f6 would be a bit helpful
would it not as it then opens up this
rook for 7th ranked defense so white
plays Bishop to f4 this is a good move
and also by not making this capture
maybe even white retains the option of
pushing and trying to show that this
past pawn can be a great inconvenience
to black
night at this stage hmm it's tough to
suggest what to do in this situation
here because the night on f5 he is
positioned on the black side of the
board and it's hard to see how this
bishop on g6 is any better than the
night it feels like when when you look
at this position you may want to view it
as if the knight and the bishop on g6
are kind of offsetting and just kind of
viewing it where you know at some point
they're going to be exchanged in the
resulting position really what we're
going to be working with is dark square
bishop s-- versus one another in two
rooks versus one another so short story
they're exchanged at this point Bishop
takes Knight G takes bishop F take C
rook to e1 this is a good move important
not to just immediately recapture why
not develop a new piece he's not playing
on a one so rook to e1 this pawn is
pinned to the King hit twice defended
zero so he's not going anywhere
Bishop d6 Bishop takes Bishop this
position has opened up quite a bit the
white rooks are perfectly placed and the
rook on a8 is out of play so black is in
a tough spot here king d7 c4 preparing
to take advantage of this pinned piece
c5 stops the advance and now Bishop
takes on takes and this pond he is
doubled but he serves a very useful role
now providing an excellent pivot Square
for the white rook rook e6 for the
moment material is balanced again not so
healthy upon here these double def pawns
mm kind of offset in a way by just the
one black pawn the G pun but again this
this pawn here
serves a good roll a six is guarded this
is an excellent pivot square and now
there's no defense of the d6 pawn he
will fall and fall with check soon
enough
so what black tries is to finally get
that rook activated doubling on the
h-file now looking for some checks here
against the white king rook takes d King
runs white steps up moving forward here
striking yet a weak points e5 there's a
check thrown in there really isn't a
good way to coordinate the black rooks
there's no fear by white or there
shouldn't be any fear by the white king
here it's just easily dodged checks at
this point eventually black will have to
address the threat against c5 another
check kingi for now this is defended
white throws in a check King to b8 that
may seem a little bit awkward to do that
instead of stepping up here but you know
by playing to b8 or I should say if you
are to play - b7 what white can do is
play to g6 and now this pawn is looking
to be captured with check so black wants
to just steer clear of that type of idea
additionally if after King b7 rook g6
even if this pawn is defended another
thing is that this rook can make use of
the seventh rank and this G pond will be
picked up in this once maybe not so
healthy looking a situation here with
the double deft pawns well he actually
turns out to be a serious asset if the
Jeep on is eliminated he's just a few
squares away from promoting so in the
game after rook c6 it was king b8 rook
d7 now one rook on the seventh white
defends against f2 rook f8 rook c7 rook
takes F
so white has these nice rooks on the
seventh ranked Black has some pressure
against f2 it's black however that is
clearly on their heels here their king
is cut off and extremely vulnerable to
checkmate on the eighth rank trying to
transfer one of the white rooks to the
8th ranked could generate some threats
here clearly against the black king so
we see this happen next with rook b7
rook D to c7 and now this is a nice
little sequence here inserting those
checks only at this point taking on g7
and now there are these threats of
delivering made against black he's
forced to go back and well actually at
this point after King to c8 it is at
this point that Castle Sparra resigned
there really isn't much resistance to
put up here another try at this point
after rook takes on G is to commit your
rook to defending here actually that's
not even working either because of mate
and one route to b8 so you could try and
stop one but not both King to c8 what
would have followed if the game was to
continue is another pawn grab there's
nothing wrong with that and this is
threatened mate King to b8 let's say we
could insert this check and also welcome
since as white we're up now two pawns
welcome a rook exchange and this will
pretty much do the trick
rooks later will have to be exchanged
here otherwise black will be getting
mated in short order with rook to a8
rook to f8 and after the smoke clears
here white is up for many reasons
material wise a couple pawn advantage
King position wise rook advantage
everything is going in White's favour
and there really would not be any hope
if the game was to continue so this was
quite the positional game
if there's one one moment where I
thought there's a way to improve on the
black end I thought it was right about
this moment here move 15 this decision
with the light square bishop was in my
opinion at least an extremely important
one applying to h7 maintaining the
bishop on this diagonal this idea of
playing g4 and then sinking the knight
in to f5 he's too strong a piece
eventually he was taken out and there
was what there was no longer that
advantage on the black end of having the
bishop pair and white could slowly
improve the King position and show this
show that the majority on the King side
was in fact real and it an adjustment
here is to instead play instead of
playing to h7 to tuck the bishop back
that way you're still keeping a watchful
eye over f5 if g4 in this case black can
now play g6 and just rule out Knight to
f5 altogether the problem in this case
is that on Bishop h7 g 4 you can't
defend g5 like this for one you're
dropping h6 well the other reason is
maybe even more serious you've just
hemmed in you've imprisoned your own
light square bishop compared the
positions of Bishop on h7 or would you
rather have him on d7 so I think that
this is really the this was a big
decision in the game
choosing h7 instead of let's say going
back to d7 turned out to be a big big
deal and a white converted that very
nicely it was a very nice
positional victory out of this Roy Lopes
Berlin defense
so as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care
you